so you're an entrepreneur in 2019 look
and live that laptop lifestyle but like
most people you're overwhelmed with the
choices out there if you're like me and
owned a number of companies and looking
to live the econ life chances are you're
looking between an Apple MacBook Pro and
the brand-new Microsoft Surface laptop -
today we're going to go through both of
these machines but first play the intro
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel as
mentioned today we're going to be
looking at two very powerful machines
hopefully with the right selection
either of these two are gonna be able to
run any program you need so with that
being said let's dive straight into what
these machines are capable of and what
kind of programs you're most likely
going to be running as an econ
entrepreneur in 2019 all right so let's
get started by taking a look at the
Apple MacBook Pro there's lots of
versions of Apple MacBook Pro and
chances are you're not going to need the
top-of-the-range which comes in at about
three-and-a-half thousand dollars if not
more depends where you live if you just
starting a dropshipping store you're
more than likely going to be ok with
running an i5 processor and maybe about
128 gigs of space and also pairing that
with a Google Drive account or a Dropbox
account just to fill out all that extra
storage and be able to work as mobile as
possible but if you're running a full
branded store in 2019 you're really
gonna have to step up your game and make
sure you stand out from the crowd
there's a lot of people in the industry
now that are pumping out content day in
day out and there's really quite a lot
of processing power required from one of
these machines to pump up that quality
when you're importing full resolution of
RAW files from something like a Canon 6d
which I'm filming on right now into the
MacBook Pro hopefully you're going to be
running an i7 processor in my personal
opinion there's only three things that
you need to have in your machine
it's an i7 processor 8 gigs of ram at
minimum and also a dedicated graphics
card there are a few drawbacks when you
grab a brand new MacBook Pro for
instance they run to USB C port as much
as I love USB C they're not really up
into the market at the moment you're
going to need to buy brand new flash
drives or different cables
different connectors it's a bit of a
pain especially when you're trying to
run things off your USB or even into an
external storage or even just exporting
files from your camera not having a USB
3 port in 2019 is still a bit
hit-and-miss in my personal opinion but
you can always grab different hubs and
different adapters to make it a bit
easier so it's not the end of the world
if you're looking to live that laptop
lifestyle as an econ entrepreneur and
maybe you want to live outside or travel
the world live in Bali
whatever it is you're looking to do you
might be working outside quite a bit now
there's a bit of a con to working
outside and that's a sunlight sunlight
can be so harsh and hard to work with
the outside on your laptop especially if
your screen isn't capable of pumping out
high volumes of backlighting one of the
advantages over the MacBook Pro versus
the surfs laptop - in my personal
opinion is the screen is just that
little bit better and a little bit
brighter which makes it just that much
easier to work outside in any location
on the brightest sunniest day if you
aren't really aware most companies
actually designed their software to run
on a Windows operating system versus the
Mac OS but that doesn't mean these
software programs don't work on the
Apple MacBook everything I use today
runs perfectly on Apple so there's no
need for you to be considering maybe one
of these programs isn't going to work or
what happens finding this different
program
chances are we live in a pretty modern
society now that everything is going to
be compatible if you're sitting there
thinking well wonder what kind of
programs he uses from day and day out
well there's about four that I use every
single day
it's Photoshop Lightroom illustrator and
Premiere Pro I'm going to go through all
these programs in a different video with
lots of different tutorials and
instructional guides how they can be
useful for your econ business but today
let's continue with the review of the
surface laptop - now before we continue
with the review of the surface laptop -
I want you guys to pause the video and
let me know in the comments below if you
think I'm a Windows guy or an apple guy
do you think I'm using this machine here
or the other one we just took a look at
okay so why would you pick the surface
laptop - over the MacBook Pro well for
starters the surf
laptop two comes in a lot cheaper than
the MacBook Pro if you go on to the top
of the range model as this one is here
it comes in just under three grand now
I've selected a surface laptop 2 for a
couple of reasons one the sleek and
stylish design of the unit to the fact
that it's pitch black I love that about
this laptop and three it's able to
produce some incredible respects it
basically has everything that I need to
be able to set up a remote workday
anywhere around the world now I do have
a concern with the surface laptop - and
it's really going to be determined by
time if that concern is factual or not
basically when you open up the laptop
you're gonna see this a posted keyboard
surface now a bit worried that the
longer you spend on your laptop resting
your wrists on it the sweater it gets in
a hot day in a bad environment that it's
gonna start staining and leaving marks
now you can't really remove this fabric
if you try you will pretty much destroy
the laptop trust me I've taken a look at
videos and I've thought about it but
hopefully it lasts and it holds up
that's one of my personal drawbacks over
posting this over the MacBook Pro
there's another thing about the surface
laptop - that kind of gets me a little
bit worried underneath this little
section here is the trackpad and when
you do click it together you can feel
the screen pressing on the trackpad and
clicking now it is a little bit of a
concern because I'm always worried that
that means the screen is a very thin and
very close to the top of the case which
means you could break it while traveling
slipping into your bag and it's always a
little bit of a worry for me if you do
purchase one of these surface laptop
twos you're going to be wanting to go
for the top of the range if you are
running a branded store if you're not if
you're just writing a dropshipping store
and you can buy lower end models which
do come in a little bit cheaper than the
MacBook Pros at about $1,500 again I'll
link some stuff down in the description
below hopefully you can get a good
overview of everything that's possible
to buy on the market today ok so what's
the conclusion are we a MacBook family
or are we a Windows family well I don't
know your business model so I can't
really recommend you the best laptop to
buy but you do and hoping the
information
giving you is going to help you make
that choice if you're running a drop
shipping store or anything similar and
you're really just working on emails and
on your Shopify store most of the day I
would 100% recommend the Apple MacBook
Pro because it is going to last a lot
longer the battery life wise and it's
also going to give you a much better
picture and clarity outside in the
daylight now if you're running a branded
store you're gonna need a very powerful
machine both of these options do come in
an i7 option but because the surface
laptop is almost $700 cheaper I open to
the surface laptop as it is just as
powerful just as good and it's a
windows-based operating system and
that's something I know a lot better
than Apple I also don't carry an iPhone
around so I don't need the Apple
compatibility like most people do which
is a great advantage for me if however
you are carrying around an Apple and
have lots of Apple products then
potentially the extra 700 olives may be
worth it for you because it's gonna
allow you to really integrate your
workflow and speed things up a lot more
down the track and that's it from me
guys hopefully you found this video
helpful and you one step closer to
picking your new econ entrepreneur
laptop I'm going to be releasing an econ
video every Monday from here on in so
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:19 style and i've seen the next one
[Music]
you
[Music]